i listening andrews
you are weird oh hell no i'm gonna
find you out thank you andrew
you you suck
i hate you why are they angry he's
speaking he's speaking realities why you
gonna get mad because he's telling you
this guy's from queens yeah me like i
don't know what happens
one of the most searched men on the
internet right now with a lot of
controversial takes we want to find out
what new yorkers think about him we're
asking people about andrew tate i
hate that guy
if you are listening and you see you are
weird
trafficker is a ball she's listening
she called me and i'll teach her how to
dress like a lady jesus she looks like
the result of feminine these dumb broads
idiot and i want to see him suffer i
agree i have to agree with that imagine
andrew tate said that i want to see my
enemies suffer like this the hypocrisy
in the left is the funniest thing in the
world i know but it's she's exaggerating
no i know i know but it is it is so
hypocritical because if you said any of
these things that the leftists say but
with the work the roles reversed even as
a joke yes i know end of the world end
of the world the nuclear bomb will go
off in your house how do you feel about
the fact that he has like a lot of fans
and he's the most searched man on the
internet right now and he has a lot of
impressionable young fans that actually
believe that this is the way to be a man
i honestly hate that especially with
like new men you know like i have this
unbuttoned like come and get me look
what is that that is disgusting and then
they get mad when men don't respect them
haram he has a pretty misogynistic
father like he doesn't respect women
thank god for his mom i want to teach
him how to respect women especially at
such an impressionable age you're going
to teach the best for our new generation
of men and here are some things that he
says
a man who sleeps with 200 women is the
man a woman who sleeps with 200 men is
worthless
he sounds like he
sucks we're asking people about andrew
tate he's a she has some interesting
takes women are property what do you
think about that
this is a person this is yes this is
andrew tate this is disgusting it's a
disgusting mentality just to think about
it like the fact that these human beings
exist and it's gross and it's awful this
dude's a fruitcake too he's the reason
why these people think that because he
takes everything out of context the way
he asks them but what bothers me the
most is that none of them go
none of them ask about context none of
them ask about background
nobody asks about anything they're like
disgusting you know why it also it's
like that it's because the schools don't
teach you anymore to look into stuff and
ask for context and look at it they ask
they ask you to just blindly comply so
if that's what these people see on the
instagram stories the fact checkers and
the headlines and that's just what
they're going to believe honestly it's
not even a lot of these bozo's fault
it's literally how they've been
indoctrinated from a young age to
believe and percept new information but
i'm going to take it back to 1950 part
of the reason for that is because and
and you know i worked your childhood too
it's not i'm not [ __ ] on everybody
but the reality is you got two parents
working no there's very little time
spent with children from the parents
teaching them how to think and and how
to really consider things you're like
rushing in the morning eating breakfast
getting getting [ __ ] shoes on let's
go get in the car drop the kid off pick
the kid up after after school day care
feed at dinner run it to a sport put it
to sleep nobody's spending real time
with these kids so the teachers fed by
the schools are just banging out the
facts that they're taught as spew and
they're not teaching the children i
think so that's what it is it takes back
to 1950 when the mother was home i
literally said this and you call me
crazy when the dad got home you know
they had time to spend together yeah i
said this i said that was a big reason
for the feminist movement why they
wanted to get the mother out of the
house so the kids would be in school
who's controlling their brains now oh
you did say that yeah yeah yeah and you
were like i don't know now you just said
it in a different way wow isn't that
funny he's a guy that probably has mommy
issues
and he probably got hurt but you don't
see other guys thank god you guys have
your masks on you guys are really saving
lives doing that they move on with their
lives everybody moves on if you got your
heart broken oh wow another thing he
says is that men build everything you
see around you women built nothing so
their place is at home and cooking this
[ __ ] guy i'm not even going to no
let's just just let it go
thank you andrew taylor
not only did you traffic women like
proudly like and you have this whole
hustler's university pyramid scheme that
you run yeah and hassan did own you on
that twitch stream you are a loser i
think that he won is just promoting
him harmful stereotypes and violence
towards like someone's wearing lingerie
in public also just like non-binary
people because i can't even imagine what
he thinks about that i think that's not
outdoor clothing other ladies if you're
watching oh he's an angry clown that's
better than clothing
the most ironic part of it at all of it
all is they're calling him a gay if i
call him gay or if i call someone gay
i'm i'm [ __ ] uh oh my god anti-lgbtq
why are you calling someone gay that's
wrong but these woke liberals can go and
call and you take a closeted kid what do
you mean by that honey what do you mean
what's wrong with it is that bad is it
bad to be gay and it's not bad to be gay
so what's your point there [ __ ] like
what are you saying right these people
are [ __ ] psychotic it's a it's a
mental disease it's a mental disease
no it is that's a little much but like
young boys now being convinced that this
is the way you need to approach women
and this is why things are going wrong
with women but that's not how you talk
to women at all or anyone who really
promotes violence against women and all
the men following it following in his
footsteps are pretty much writing their
own jails what he says
so she's she's this one's complaining
that he promotes violence against women
but let's cut out the event against
women just promotes violence did you see
how she came at the camera i'm gonna
stick a big nine inch purple dildo up
your ass yeah that you actually have you
didn't have to include that part so
she's not promoting violence no just one
it's not okay for him to perceive
promote violence where she can okay a
closeted kid
okay i wish i wish she would expand on
what she means by that the man who
sleeps with 200 women is the man but a
woman who sleeps with 200 men
is worthless it's called the misogynist
men sleep with who they can for the most
part and women sleep with who they want
to that is the truth so if a woman goes
and sleeps with 200 men that means that
she wanted to and that she just opened
her legs and let it happen i know this
is where we kind of disagree but that is
the truth if a man sleeps with 200
people he has to earn it to sleep with
200. we just didn't disagree on that i
just don't hear you saying things so
crass let's just carry on all right
whatever uh way that is brain like just
like so the mental illness i think like
what are your thoughts totally like a
mental health illness
he is everything wrong and hateful with
the world right now you're gonna ask are
you guys muslim yes yes we are
we muslims are in a predicament because
he said some really good things about
islam
he said that islam is the last religion
no one can go against it you could find
a bunch of women who adhere to islam who
are still virgin to the age of 25
waiting for an enraged marriage oh yeah
you will not find that under
christianity how do you feel like he
said good things about islam but now
he's saying all these things about women
just because you say nice things about
islam if you're going to say hateful
things about women i think that says
that you don't actually understand that
much about islam because propaganda
these these are women you have to value
droids this is actually a smarter woman
because it's it's sad because she sounds
more intelligent she just doesn't know
what he actually says right because
they're saying like if if he actually
did say hateful things toward women then
towards women yes you have a good point
it doesn't justify it because at least
she's responding with reason and
intelligence not going after him with
violence
but she still is just uneducated and
doesn't understand that he doesn't
promote violence and hate against women
it's this is just stupid can you say
such hateful things and how can you make
money off of cam girls and then also try
and gain the muslim population's like
respect i think just because you say one
thing your behavior shows a lot more
than that for example just because
somebody honestly not a horrible point
either i agree he says one thing that i
agree with that doesn't mean that i'm
going to take everything that they say
as the truth from then on out islam is
such a loving religion and the quran
says nothing but equality and peace and
love between both genders and respect
between both genders and he stands for
everything against that if you have a
message for andrew tape i hope that he
gets love
in his life because he obviously doesn't
and
i hope that he sees the true way of the
world now the true way of islam if
that's truly what you believe in and
that's something that you aspire to
believe in and follow and i hope you
just leave women alone we've had enough
trouble recently and you adding on with
all of your violence and hatred is
unfathomable he has some interesting
takes on women and i want you guys to
just tell me what you think about what
he says okay then women are incompetent
we all know that women can't do anything
as soon as i needed police help and two
women turned up i knew the game was i
knew they were useless of course they
are the women i think he's a little
[ __ ] boy
he was talking about a hit and run on
his someone stole his car if you get
your car stolen call me sexist i want a
man helping me out mom i want a man is
that the craziest thing no no no grandma
grandma was talking this morning while
you were the best grandma face grandma
was telling me reminding me today of a
of a story that we know about so family
friend used to be an nypd detective
before that he was a beat cop and early
on when women started entering the
police force yeah
he got partnered they started partnering
women up with men and they were in a
real bad neighborhood and over and over
again they got called to a particular
house for domestic violence it was a
fourth floor walk-up apartment in
brownsville and there they would go up
there this one cop that we knew he went
up there all the time when he got paired
with this female cop they went up there
this one time and you know he knew the
people already he talked them off the
ledge calmed them down quelled the
situation and the female cop says we
need to take him out of here get him out
of here this is ridiculous blah blah
blah starts like getting all tough now
the guy that we know like you know 510
511 trim this female cop was about five
inches shorter than him also trim tiny
and the male cop knew how to diffuse the
situation and deal with it because the
man in this domestic violence situation
was a brick [ __ ] house he was giant and
so he says to her he says to the female
cop oh yeah you want to arrest him you
want to get this guy angry down four
flights of stairs god how about it you
know perfect example of when you're in a
bad situation you have four floors that
you're at a fourth story walk up and
there's a brick [ __ ] house beating you
up do you want little tr trina showing
up with her attitude or do you want some
some big strong men coming in to help
you i want the dudes unless trina has
some magical powers that she can calm
everything down and the only reason the
the male officer did was because he had
a history with these people and they
trusted him and they knew him so tate
saying that isn't really that
controversial and for these women to
take insults i mean do you want me
one of our videos was like i can't do a
push-up you want me coming in to pull
you right over a fiery inferno no i
don't no i'm good never i've been gotten
a piece
he's a face and he can go himself
because you know what next time you're
in a you're in a big problem let's just
let's just have women cops come and show
up you know next time there's a man
trying to trying to hurt you or rape you
let's get a bunch of women to come and
save you you [ __ ] idiot you were
these people are incompetent it's very
competent we give birth like we do so
much we do everything
exactly you give birth and you do a lot
you don't need a save [ __ ] you don't
need to be a cop and do gta 5 missions
bimbo who claims you would be so
successful shouldn't be on the internet
begging for attention all the time she
actually said that a man who cries the
woman
talks
that
she's ugly and fat so she's with him
because he cries a real woman would be
with a man that doesn't cry
because i'm like what the like men have
feelings too
why is he putting out this message that
alpha male like can we like forget about
that for a second and realize everyone's
human that's definitely taken out of
context too so i'm not even it's taken
out of context there's no way i think
what he said is if you cry in front of
your girl and she loses respect for you
which i don't agree with if you cry all
the time like i said it depends on the
scenario it was like acting like tommy
which got you taught me when i was like
yeah this guy's crying at night in bed
yeah that's bad but he's not wrong
because as a man you are supposed to be
the leader and the strong person in the
relationship so if you're there crying
it's like [ __ ] this is my leader go to
the gym hit the bag let it out and women
should do that too we should be sitting
around crying but i'm not even saying
that it's not okay to cry as a man it's
just like in scenarios i think what i
think what happened is though these
young girls
have taken this have taken men can cry
to such an extreme like they do with
everything he could cry yeah really wait
until you're 40. wait until these girls
are 40 and they're married to pink tommy
and he's crying in bed every night
they're going to be out looking for tape
guaranteed and they would argue with me
all day right now trust me been there
done that go out says depression doesn't
exist oh jesus doesn't make any sense
because i've been on antidepressants for
the last five years because i have a
chemical imbalance like they like they
tell every everyone you will you have a
chemical imbalance take these pills i'm
sorry they say i know but i i don't want
to [ __ ] on this girl for that because
who knows what she's been through
i'm at risk you just look a little crazy
mental health issues do you have a
message for andrew tate what would it be
uh use science and not idiocy you need
to like accept your name first and then
start accepting others like this shows
how the [ __ ] irony of that sentence
you science not what is what was it
idiocy yeah like that okay don't get me
don't you know what the things that are
on the tip of my tongue right now i'm
not gonna say like we just went over how
a man is more capable to do the gta 5
missions as a police job science
dumbass here you are and how messed up
your life could be you need help stop
spreading dangerous messages to people
and work on being true to yourself and
confident in yourself
life's too short to be as negative as
you are spread some positivity bro like
for real
because everything you see is built by
men what did women build
this dude's an agent no you didn't feel
that you didn't make a life without a
man
you can't we're not self-impregnating
vehicles he won't mention that he also
said that women life is more precious
and more valuable than man's life and if
[ __ ] hits the fan the man's dying first
why the [ __ ] would he say uh or ask them
i get i get he's trying to do this
reviews but he's an agent of the matrix
it's as simple as that because then all
of these people that come on and they
haven't listened to entertain talk and
they just want to see an interview and
this this is their perception of him
what this bimbo says built any of this
if it wasn't for women women nowadays
are building a lot too a woman is his
product and whatever
you just say they wouldn't have built
any of this if it wasn't for women i
like the old saying you know behind
every strong man as a good woman and or
good man as a woman whatever it is
because i do think that it takes a team
and a lot of that is because the woman
was home taking care of [ __ ] so this guy
could could build women are great
architects too they can do it great
engineers they can do it but don't act
like where's she in new york she's it
looks like she's somewhere that's 200
years old no women didn't build that
pumpkin sorry the dudes did a woman is
his product and whatever she's making
should give him 80 of what she makes
well obviously that mindset is very
problematic and wrong in every which way
and if anyone believes that then you
need help
so unsubscribe for me
i don't know what you're doing women are
smarter in every way honestly my girl is
if you had a message for andrew state
what would it be
no girly gnome
that's all skye is a legend do you know
who andrew state is of course that's the
goal right there that's my boy
i don't know who that is
you're a different take now because
everybody here was like really angry
towards them so tell me what you think
about why they angry he's speaking he's
speaking reality why are you going to
get mad cause he's telling you to treat
me like a king and you want to be
treated like a queen but i don't
understand what's wrong with society
today if you had a message for andrew
tape what would it be look straight to
the camera oh
educate i'm not gonna lie you said you
was gonna get jake paul of bugatti you
know i'm saying i'm looking for bugatti
if you want to give me a call you know
what i'm saying it could be a honda 2018
you know what i'm saying
i'm saying
what i'm saying
that's it my boy keep doing your thing
keep doing your thing all right that is
the only person with those two those two
girls in the beginning were probably
from the bronx that guy he's not from
queens i'm gonna go he's a brooklyn or
the bronx that guy but he's a real new
yorker too everyone else was a
transplant join the rumble because we
are so bound to just be doomed by
getting banned soon because truth does
not sit well especially in election
seasons yeah no we're going to get
screwed over i just want to say it also
that i really appreciate everybody you
know half of our we he can look at the
data of who's watching these videos and
half of you out there are u.s and the
other half is global and i i am not a
particularly cosmopolitan woman and i
really appreciate that and it kind of
makes me want to go visit all the places
that you're watching us from so i really
appreciate that and thank you thank you
all we love you
later
[Music]
won't guys long